What kind of music you're listening to.
I listen to everything that they do.
I listen to. I was in a lot of classic
rock for whatever reason. But uh,
I've been listening a lot of Kanye West
over the last few weeks talking about
Kanye. Yeah, well he's talking about
a lot of crazy shit. He's tired.
He actually talked about DMT in one of
his recent songs. He did that before.
I think he did. Oh Man. Why know
he's friends with kid cuddie kid cut.
He'd been in here and kid cut. He's
had some psychedelic experiences. Yeah.
Once you go to is your thumb, you didn't
want to do nothing else again. Well,
puts it all in the perspective.
It lets you see that, uh,
as much as this thing seems
to be important is all
temporary and you're a part
of forever and it also allows you
to become comfortable with death.
Yeah. Yeah. You know who said that?
Larry Hagman remember
that Guy Dallas from jr?
He did an interview with CNN and I dream
of Jeannie as well. Yeah, that's right.
He sprung it on him on CNN.
Once he was talking about how he did acid,
he took a big dose of acid and he's
never worried about death ever again.
That it just alleviated his,
his worry about passing on as wow,
this shit that could,
I felt the same way I feel I have.
It doesn't matter anymore. Yeah.
I think DNT even more specifically
because they think the mind that way.
What causes the effect of mine?
That way they don't tell him
that his main Gig visioning,
visualize everything. They don't totally
know. They know that your brain makes it.
They know that your body makes it,
they should say and they know that it's
produced in your liver and their lungs
and there's some evidence now
cause they found it in rats,
that the pineal gland produces it,
which is like,
that's the third eye of eastern
mysticism that Glenn actually in rats,
they've proven produces DMT and they
think it does so on people too. You know,
once I did,
I wanted to do it again and again and
again and if they shouldn't do too much of
my laugh with me, I got to,
you know, grasp what's going
on here. Why am I feeling?
It's like, why? Why did this in
a weird way, like humbled you.
I don't think you should listen
to the people say you shouldn't,
you know too much. I think you
just do it as much as you want.
That's what I agree with too.
Yeah, I agree. You could handle it.
If you can handle being like Tyson, you
can handle doing DMT issues, EMT. Yeah,
that's what I think I'm going,
I'm going in that direction. Well,
I mean it's not something you
just do all day every day,
but you can learn a lot from it.
It's an and it's,
it's very beneficial and very
strange that it's illegal.
You know that it's illegal.
Yeah.
Notice that Mckenna had a joke about
it because your body is making it so
everybody's holding, we all
have it. You know, it's illegal,
but it's like making blooded legal.
Everybody has.
And then why would he go into scenario
data when he find these tolls? Yeah. Yeah.
I've never experienced it from the toad
of owning a television where the way
they extract and grab them and they
squeezed pimples and they busted on the
class a marrow and then take it off
and he let it harden. Yeah, they,
they let it dry in the sun. They
scrape it off with a razor blade. Yeah.
I've only had it a synthetically
made in a laboratory.
You smelled a buy it online. Used to be
able to buy like a of fucking can of it.
Like this big enough to get like a whole
state high. She's just buy it online.
It was totally legal. Credible. Yeah.
It's weird design. It is illegal.
Well they would say not
for human consumption,
but I don't know what the fuck are you
doing with it if you're not using it for
human consumption but you,
you used to be able to buy.
I've never felt anything like that
before. No, nothing like that.
Make me not want to do anything.
Nothing else can supersede that.
How long ago did it happen?
Around two months ago. Yeah.
Did you write down what happened after
it happened or did you record it? No,
I wish I did. Yeah, we should
that. Yeah, me too. If you like,
it goes away like a dream, right? It comes
off. You know, you're, you're so scared.
You know stuff like this.
No, no, no. Ne,
Hey, I want this to stop now. And the
guy was like, hey, you're on the right.
And I'm like, no, no, no.
Yeah, I love it. I love you.
I love you.
Yeah. I'd love everybody.
Yeah. So spassed out. Yeah.
Did you have a hard time letting go?
And the beginning of fighting me,
I don't think stop wanting to stop now.
Just jump. Stop this shit now stopping.
The guy was like, hey, the show. I'm like,
I can do it. You got to go for the ride,
dude. And it was like,
whoa man. Like I'm dying.
Things are going in my film theme,
the Aztec things. I'm being told,
I'm just seeing weird animal.
The thing is flying, it's just,
it's like another chamber. It's boom
flashing. Foom. He'd gone and take a walk.
Are you taking off foom yeah.
It's beyond your imagination.
Yeah. DEF is inconceivable. Can't
even explain it to no one. Well,
I'm hoping that um,
the,
they start with psilocybin because a,
I know maps there.
They're doing some great work with that,
trying to get these things legalize
especially they're doing MTMA studies with
veterans and people with Ptsd
and they're having great results.
They're moving into civil side bend.
They would love to get silicide
been legal and it's up for ballot.
I think it was in Oregon. Is
that where it is? It's up for,
I think Oregon is up for legalization
this year and it may be eventually in
California as well. They may do
addition, it should be legal.
It doesn't kill anybody. It should be,
it's not a bad thing if they regulate it,
if they make it for therapeutic use and
just set up centers where experts can
show,
but they shouldn't make it prohibitive
for people to own it or even grow their
own. It's not a bad idea to set up
places where people can do it under a,
a professionals care, a showman's care.
Physicians Care, that's a good idea.
But making it illegal is a
bad idea because it helps
a lot of people, you know,
people think of it as a party drug.
They think you're going to do mushrooms
and freak out and go fucking run around
naked.
And He's do much as I love mushrooms,
will psilocybin and DMT or very
closely related chemically,
all those really potent psychedelic
drugs are very closely related.
They all break down in some
similar path inside your brain and,
and give you that,
that weird
ego dissolving experience.
You know, that's one thing.